we're not having any kind of smart
conversation
at a national level in fact it's almost
as if
we've destroyed every sandbox
in which we could play together there's
no place
that we actually talk except long-form
podcasting
and by the way they've found you see
what's going on with like alex stamos
and the hoover institution we've you
know
there's a loophole left long-form
podcasting
allows people to speak at levels above
daytime cnn
yeah it's like well why do you think
they're not watching daytime cnn
but you know that's that's just silly
journalism they
uh currently have no power to displace
podcasts that's why it's so powerful rss
feed i mean that's why
the big challenge with joe rogan and
spotify is like there's this dance
that's fascinating to see
is joe rogan is now part of the system
and then he's also uncancelable and
there's this
tension that's happening well howard
stern
howard stern became much less relevant
so if they can't control joe by bringing
him in house
the key question is is he going to
continue
like you know this joe says this thing
about fu money
yeah joe's one of the only people with
fu money who's actually said
fu yeah yeah
i don't understand this i don't have fu
money
what exactly is can we break apart
few money because i always thought
i've been fortunate enough to
have always have fu money in the sense
that my standards were so low
that a basic salary in the united states
this is the stoic point which is it you
can
live on rice and beans right you're
uncancelable because you're always rich
relative to your needs
right isn't that fu fundamental if you
mind why do you say that tech
billionaires don't have fu money
when you need to hire private security
to protect your family
how do you protect your two children i
don't have those yet bingo
yeah my point is is that fu money
insulates everything that you care about
it's not just about you
so you're saying as the level of
responsibility grows
the amount of money required for fu
we have a war going on the war is on
academic freedom
academic freedom used to be present in
the system as a
in terms of the idea we we trust our
elite
now we have an idea like you want to be
the elite
you know you want a lord above us that's
like first of all there's like a
populist anti-elitist thing
then there's the idea that um we're
gonna defer
tenure for forever then we're going to
tell people stay in your lane your
tenure is only good for your own
particular tiny micro subject
then we're going to also control your
grants and we'll be able to
load up your teaching load if we don't
like who you are will make your life
absolutely impossible we lost
academic freedom and we ushered in peer
review
which was a disaster and then we
lost funding so that people were
confident that
they would have the ability to do
research no matter what they said
and as a result what you find is is a
world in which there's no ability
to get people to say no i'm not going to
sign your diversity and inclusion
forced loyalty oath i won't sign any
loyalty oath
get the hell out of my office that's
you f you and you're you're connecting
money to that but
well my point is is that academic
freedom is
the the whole idea behind it was that
you will have the freedom of a
billionaire
on a much smaller salary right okay
we've lost that yeah the only reason in
part
that i wanted to go into
academic academics as a profession as
opposed to
wanting to do physical or mathematical
research
the great prize was freedom and ralph
gomorry
of the sloan foundation previously of
ibm research pointed it
out he says if if you lose freedom you
lose the only thing we had to offer top
minds top
minds value their intellectual freedom
and their physical and
economic security at a different level
than other human beings
and so people say you know
i understand dude you have the ability
to do x y and z what's the problem
it's like well i value my ability to
raise the middle finger as an american
practically above everything else
you